if you are 22 years old you are entering
first of all some of the greatest years
of your life because you have to
understand this next five year window is
when you don't go practical and safe
this is not the time to get the job Mom
wanted you to this is not the time to
try to maximize as much money so you can
buy a fat whip what you should do is go
and travel and learn go and start that
business that you've always wanted this
is the time to be massively risked
massively risk oriented but boy if
you're lucky enough to be graduating
today with not a [__] idea of what
you're going to do with your future
nobody's ever been luckier than you
please recognize it